THROUGH BEAUTIFUL NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT'S WHAT'S IS COMING TO.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT SOMETHING,
TONIGHT, EVERY STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES IS A BORDER STATE.
AS WE SPEAK, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SHAPING
ILLEGAL ALIENS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING ONE THAT JUMP
OFF THE PAGE, TENNESSEE WERE
ACCORDING TO FOXNEWS.COM, SCORE
OF SINGLE ADULT ILLEGALS ARE
SAID TO BE RELEASED PENDING
COURT PROCEEDINGS.
HERE AND OUT WITH MORE IS
TENNESSEE SENATOR MARSHA
BLACKBURN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
WE HAVE HEARD NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES,
THEY ARE FAMOUSLY AND IN BRAVAD
FASHION CENTURY STATES, ONE TO
COME ONE, COME ALL.
TENNESSEE IS DIFFERENT, HOW DID
YOU FIND OUT THAT YOU TAKE IT
YES INDEED, THAT GOVERNOR WAS
NOTIFIED THAT THEY WERE GOING T
BEGIN TO BRING THESE AS YOU SAI
SINGLE ADULT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INTO TENNESSEE WHILE THEY WAIT
FOR THEIR COURT PROCEEDING, THE
ARE WORKING WITH THE TENNESSEE
IMMIGRATION AND REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM AND GOING
TO PUT THEM IN TENNESSEE.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS THEY
ARE TURNING EVERY STATE INTO A
BORDER STATE FREIGHT EVERY TAIL
INTO A BORDER TOWN.
HOW TO DEAL WITH THIS SITUATION
AT THE BORDER ONES TITLE 40 TO
GOES AWAY.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY ARE GOING TO SEND THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND SAY ALL RIGHT, TENNESSEE OR
OTHER STATES, YOU PAID THE BILL
YOU TAKE CARE OF THIS BECAUSE WE
, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN'T
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HANDLE THIS,
AND WE HAVE TO MOVE THESE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM THE
BORDER INTO OTHER AREAS WHERE
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE NOTICED
, IN TENNESSEE WE KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE 50 AT A TIME.
THEY WILL HAVE AT LEAST TWO
BUSES, MAY BE MORE EVERY SINGLE
WEEK, AND SO FAR, THAT IS WHAT
WE KNOW, WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN A
RESPONSE FROM THEM YET, BUT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND TRYING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION.
>> SOCHA MY 50 AT A TIME
MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK AND YOU
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHERE YET,
AND WHAT IS THE PLAN, DROP THEM
OFF AND HOW ARE THEY SHELTERED?
IS IT'S ON THEM OR IS THIS, WE
JUST GOT TO FIND SOMEWHERE ELSE
TO MOVE THEM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
BE IN ONE PLACE OR CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> SINCE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BROKEN THE
BORDER AND NOW WE HAVE AN OPEN
BORDER AND NOW THEY ARE SEEING
THIS SURGE, THEY HAVE TO MOVE
THEM AWAY FROM THE BORDER, SO
THIS IS THEIR PLAN, SEND THEM T
OTHER STATES, SEND THEM TO OTHE
CITIES AND LET THE TAXPAYERS IN
THOSE CITIES AND IN THOSE STATE
THE BILL FOR THE SOCIAL SERVICES
, THE EDUCATION, ALL OF
THE HEALTH THAT THESE IMMIGRANTS
, SARAH WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT HOW ABUSED THESE
INDIVIDUALS OUR IS THEY MAKE
THIS JOURNEY, THIS IS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, AND THEN
YOU ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE WITH TH
DRUGS.
THE EXPOSURE TO DRUGS, THE
FENTANYL, THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING, AND THE NUMBER OF
SERVICES, THE AMOUNT OF SERVICE
THEY WILL NEED TOO.
SO THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS SHOW
THEY ARE DISRESPECT AND THE
STATES.
THEY FEEL LIKE KEEPING THAT
POWER AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL, AND
HAVING THE STATES DO THEIR
BIDDING, THAT IS THE WAY TO
HANDLE THE MESS THAT THEY HAVE
MADE.
LET'S LET THE STATES MOPPED THI
UP FOR US.
>> THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN
FEDERALISM, THEY IGNORE THE FAC
THAT TENNESSEE MIGHT HAVE A
CERTAIN WAY OF WANTING TO DO
THINGS THAT IS A LOT DIFFERENT
THAN CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK
WHICH IS WHY PEOPLE ARE MOVING
TO TENNESSEE IN DROV